as a company that specializes in big
data analysis and integration
it has always been our passion to make
bioinformatics
more accessible we already have a
platform for learning about
bioinformatics in the context of a
project-based curriculum
but previously we downplayed the
importance of coding
in part it was due to the fact that many
biologists just don't have the time
to learn a new skill and in part it was
due to the challenges
in getting the initial setup steps and
technical issues
out of the way remotely but we soon
discovered that this is
only a part of the full solution to
close the data science gap for
non-engineers
we have to focus on all of the central
issues
that will enable anyone to be effective
at managing processing analyzing
and integrating large data that is why
today we are launching
the omics logic code playground here we
will be posting
practical coding assignments that will
help you
understand the r and python code syntax
for common types of tasks
a bioinformatician faces in day-to-day
work
as a result you will learn how to
process genomic
transcriptomic and meta-genomic data on
the cloud or dedicated high-performance
computing server stack
by launching processing pipelines that
structure and prepare data for
downstream
analysis these tasks can be easily
automated and mastered
on the tbinfo platform which offers a
streamlined process
from learning to the application of
bioinformatics and life sciences
but as soon as the data is processed the
work of a data scientist begins
you have to explore understand and
wrangle multiple tables and data frames
to find patterns
and annotate them with biological
meaning that is why in the code
playground you will find
course collections on genomics
transcriptomics
metagenomics and data science in each
course you will load transform and
visualize data
in r or python from single bar plots to
complex multi-dimensionality reduction
techniques like principle component
analysis
or clustering for data mining including
classification
and regression that will allow you to
group data objects by feature similarity
and train machine learning models for
predictive analysis
not only will you learn about the
methods you will also understand them by
applying the analysis to your own data
sets
and modifying settings to see how each
line of code
contains important instructions to
transform a
complex data set into a fascinating
discovery
from the very basics to the cutting edge
loading transformation visualization as
well as discovery of
patterns and real data sets used by
researchers to study and understand
biological phenomena at the molecular
level now code playground is a part of
our
immersive omixlogic programs where we
combine online interactive sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments using the tbi info
platform
and the coding challenges in both r and
python
so get started today at
code.omicslogic.com